we need to find the nature of roots of
the following quadratic equation notice
that we've been asked only for the
nature of the roots and not values of
the root the first thing we need to know
is that for the quadratic equation ax
squared plus BX plus C equals 0 the
roots are given by this formula and the
nature of the roots depends on this
value which is called the discriminant
if it's greater than zero and the
quadratic equation will have two
distinct real roots if it's equal to
zero then the quadratic equation will
have equal real roots and if it's less
than zero then the quadratic equation
will have no real roots keep this idea
in mind let me solve the first one for
you the first thing we need to do is
find the values of a B and C comparing
the first equation with the general form
we get the value of a at 9 B as negative
12 and C as for now it's easy to
calculate the value of b squared minus
4ac it will equal negative 12 squared
minus 4 times 9 times 4 negative 12
squared is 144 and 4 times 9 times 4 is
also 144 so we get the value of the
discriminant as 0 what does this tell us
it tells us that this quadratic equation
has to equal and real roots try pausing
for the roots and verify you answer now
I want you to try finding the nature of
the roots of the second question
comparing the second equation with the
general form we get the value of a as to
be as negative 9 and C at 4 what will be
the value of b squared minus 4ac then it
will equal 49 which is positive this
quadratic equation will have two
distinct real roots as its discriminant
is positive and you should be able to
solve the third one easily we get the
value of the discriminant at negative
seven this quadratic equation will have
no real rules you should try solving the
above equations to verify your answer
and it's a good chance for practice
[Music]